All right.
Thanks everyone for attending.
I know this is the
last talk of the day,
and I appreciate everyone here.
This is less product-oriented
than the others.
So I'm going to
assume you're all here
as die hard fans of
Production, which is what I am.
So this morning, we
heard from Joe Kava,
talking about the hardware and
data center side of the Google
Cloud platform, and
I'm here to take you
on a whirlwind tour of how
we support the software side.
My goal is that you walk out of
here understanding how Google
keeps an infrastructure
like this together,
but that you also have some
ideas that you can take home
to your teams, both
organizational and tools.
At the end, I will stay up here
if there are any questions.
And I know it's late and
everyone wants to beat traffic.
I have a set of business
cards, so if you just
want to grab one and run out
and send me your question,
I'm happy to answer it later.
All righty.
Let's get going.
So first, a bit about me.
I joined Google only a year ago.
This means I've actually
seen a lot of the places
that you guys are working.
I've worked in
10-person startups,
100-person startups,
I've worked in a retail company
attempting to reinvent itself,
and I also spent almost
a decade at Amazon,
where I was building internal
tools and automation.
If any of you are familiar
with AWS CodeDeploy,
I designed the internal
tool that's built on.
I know baby pictures
are traditional,
but I figured you would get
a lot more enjoyment out
of my 1980s haircut.
So here's a picture
me with Bob Ballard.
This has not shown
publicly before.
Enjoy it while you can.
All right.
Next, I'm going to talk about
SRE, the What and the Why.
First, I want to tell you
a story about cookies.
Everyone likes cookies.
So let's start with sys admins.
What do sys admins
get cookies for?
Sys admins get cookies
when the site stays up.
Site stays up, we get visitors,
visitors give us money.
Yay!
Cookies for everyone.
U is for uptime.
How about developers?
What do developers
get cookies for?
Developers get
cookies for features.
Release a new feature,
visitors come,
they give us even more money.
Yay!
Cookies.
Before I continue, I want to ask
you to go home and put together
an experiment.
Have your developers stop
releasing code for two weeks
and let me know what happens
to your site availability.
Maybe you guys work
at a place that
has a production freeze
for big business reports
or for holiday stuff.
The fact is that
production freezes usually
result in higher uptime.
So you have these two
competing priorities.
Your sys admins get cookies
for keeping the site up,
your developers get cookies
for releasing features.
So these two teams start
to figure things out.
The sys admins will
get more cookies
if they could prevent
teachers from going out,
and the developers
will get more cookies
if they could figure out a way
around the sys admins' rules.
So devs figure out they
can call it a beta.
It's just a beta, guys, it's OK.
Not a big deal.
And the sys admins
figure out that they
can demand launch reviews
and stretch those out
for a really long time
if you do it right.
Developers go, oh,
I have an idea.
We're going to a
percentage flag flip.
That's a good idea.
So you end up with this
fighting back and forth,
and sadness, and no cookies,
because all of your teams
are spending all their
time fighting each other.
You get increased addage,
increased risk, chaos, anarchy,
dogs and cats living together.
So what we want is
to actually take
all of this whim and
fiat out of the process,
have it handled by rules
so teams going have goals
and work together.
Now, there actually is a
common solution out there
for this to Dev and
Operations problem.
There are conferences dedicated
to Dev and Operations.
Anyone have any
idea what those are?
Yeah, DevOps.
So problem with
DevOps, I don't know
if you know the story of the
blind men and the elephant,
but it's a set a blind men who
go, and one guy feels the trunk
and it's kind of
leathery and bumpy,
and that's what he decides
the elephant looks like.
Another one feels the
tusks, long, smooth, cold.
That must be with the
elephant looks like.
Another feels the tail.
DevOps is a little
bit like this.
It has a different
meanings everywhere you go,
different interpretations.
So is agile.
So are various other things.
So I'm going to talk about
SRE, because SRE actually
is well-defined.
In short, this is SRE.
There's two key
phrases in this quote
from Ben Treynor,
"software engineer,"
and "design and run."
Software engineer is
critical, because it
turns out services run better
when people who understand
software also run it.
They have a deep understanding
of what makes it tick.
of the interactions.
And design and run.
When you actually design
your production environment
rather than having it
be a happy accident
or something some dev did while
hyped-up on some really good
coffee, right, after drinking?
You actually have a
better environment.
There are many, many
different aspects to SRE.
I am not going to try
to discuss all of them.
But it's all these activities
that actually make up
what we call SRE.
So let's say we have
a 1,000 SREs working
on Google's infrastructure,
network, compute, storage,
et cetera.
How many of them
do you guys think
are responsible for Cloud?
Maybe 100 of them, 10%?
200 of them?
I'll give you a hint.
SREs in every office we have
around the world work on Cloud.
It turns out the answer
is that all of our SREs
who support our infrastructure
also support Cloud.
We don't want to
distinguish between what
makes Google.com run and what
makes Google Cloud Platform,
and therefore, your
applications run.
We don't want to have
communication overhead
as the Cloud teams
in the internal teams
try to communicate.
We want to create
one environment that
helps everything work together.
The rest of my talk is how
we created those teams,
how we run those teams,
and how we do what we do.
So first, how do
we structure SRE
from an organizational
perspective?
How do we make sure we hire
devs into a role focused
on production?
and keep them happy?
How do we keep the team
valued inside of Google?
And how do we help our
teams communicate better
and resolve
disagreements with data,
rather than assertions
or power grabs?
So first, it's all about
leveling the playing field,
having common tools,
having common knowledge.
All of our SREs have to pass
a full software interview
to get hired.
In addition to that,
they have to pass
a non-abstract large
system design interview.
So in some senses,
although I would never
tell this to my devs who are
sitting here in front row,
our SREs actually have to be
more skilled than our devs are
to do the same job.
You need to have a
greater breadth of skills.
So it's the same software
skills, but different domain
of application.
Devs are beholden
to product managers.
They make features.
They make you guys happy.
SREs are beholden to Production.
They're beholden to
making Production
as good as it possibly can be.
So when both of these
different perspectives
contribute to a design,
the resulting design
is much stronger.
Here's an example
from an onboarding
that a friend of mine did.
They evaluated the
team's software
and they found that there
were a bunch of assumptions.
It was going to fail in
production when we hit scale.
The devs had implicitly assumed
a particular type of call
would never fail.
They had assumed the
distribution of the request
was uniform.
They'd assumed they wouldn't
get hot-spotted by users.
They'd assumed that all of their
requests were average-sized,
and they failed
on the two tails.
But that's what our
SREs bring to the table.
Then we need to give our devs
a reason not to just allow
operational work to build up.
Because if they're not doing
it, why would they care?
So we do this by having
our devs actually
provide the headcount to SRE.
So if you have a system that has
a really large open operational
overhead, you don't
get as many devs.
You don't get to push
as many features,
because we look at the
headcount in aggregate.
We also have SRE report to an
entirely separate organization.
They have their own VP
separate from the Dev VPs.
This gives them the
authority and power.
It allows them to say
no when Production
means they need to say no.
They're not just a
bunch of pager monkeys.
There's also scarcity.
The devs say that they
can donate headcount.
SRE doesn't have to accept it.
They can say,
that's great, but we
don't think that service is
actually important enough.
Why don't you keep
supporting it yourself?
Not every team at
Google has SREs.
Cloud does, but not
every other team.
And not every single
small service in Cloud.
It's the important ones.
So I'll talk a little bit more
about that on another slide,
but the main point is
that SREs are scarce.
The environment, very critical.
So this is how you actually
keep these devs happy,
running in a Production team.
You need to have at least 50%
of your work being project work.
So that's not on
call, that's not
tickets, that's not meetings.
You actually have to
be doing project work.
And if there's too
much project work,
either the devs give
more headcount to SRE,
or that actual work actually
flows over into the dev team.
Example project work
for SREs, improving
the latency of a
service by switching
the underlying
database technology,
writing automation to
speed up deployments,
and projects that span services.
We have a service
internally that
can be queried by
other services,
because we make robots
do everything for us,
not Boston Dynamics-type of
robots but softer robots.
So we have a service you can
query internally that says,
hey, is it safe to
take this machine down?
Is it safe to take
this rack down?
Could I take down
this data center
that actually syncs with the
state of everything else,
and gives a yes or a no.
And that's maintained by SRE.
And possibly most
critically, our SRE teams
are a volunteer army.
There is no draft.
Not only can you transfer
to another SRE team
at any time without your
manager's permission,
although this applies to
all devs at Google as well,
but you can transfer into Dev.
So if you're tired of
dealing with Production,
you just really want to sit
down with a product manager
and become best friends,
you can transfer to Dev.
You don't have to ask
anyone's permission to do it.
We actually even
have the reverse,
which is Mission Control, where
devs can try out SRE and see
if they like it.
One of my teams has two mission
controllers on it right now.
Really hoping they'll stay.
If you're watching this,
guys, we want you to stay.
So as a result, the
teams are fluid.
People are coming in
and out of the teams,
sharing experiences,
sharing perspectives.
And finally, we have a budget.
This isn't a money budget
like you're used to.
This is an error budget.
If I tell you, you have three
nines of service availability,
I don't want you to go, wow.
I'll bet I can push
that to 3 and 1/2,
maybe four nines if I'm
really, really good.
You have 0.1% error budget.
Go for it!
If you want to push out
features faster and make
GCP even better, do it,
right up until you run out
of error budget.
If you, instead, would
prefer to have poor tests,
have your software
failing regularly,
and have to rollback constantly,
then you can choose that, too,
but you'll run out of
error budget much faster,
and you actually won't
be able to launch.
And so, these are budgets
go in quarterly cycles.
Now, there is an
escape valve for that.
It's called Silver Bullets.
Some teams have literal,
actual silver bullets,
and a dev can come up and say,
I really, really need to push.
I really, really would like
a silver bullet, please.
And the SRE will
say, no problem.
You just have to convince the VP
that you actually need to push.
And that little ritual,
which sounds very silly,
is actually very powerful.
Because it puts it entirely
in the hands of the devs,
they know they have
three silver bullets,
and their VP is the one
that decides whether or not
it's appropriate to push.
This even applies if you have
multiple dev teams working
on the service, because
error budgets are
on a per-service
basis, not per-team.
So SRE does not get in the
middle of warring dev teams.
They have to work out amongst
themselves how that error
budget's going to be spent.
So we do have an escape valve.
If all else fails, there is
an irreconcilable dispute,
SRE can off-board-- it's the
opposite of onboarding-- a dev
team.
Basically, we've loved
working with you guys.
We have irreconcilable
differences.
Kind of like an
amicable divorce.
It's rare, but it has happened.
It's a very critical
escape valve
to make sure that you
don't have teams festering
disagreements for long periods.
An example reason
for this might be
if you have, say, a common
database at Google that's
encouraged for all new
asset-type projects,
we might call it
Spanner, and new projects
are supposed to use it.
The devs team says, you
know, Spanner's cool and all.
We're going to go build our own.
It's very reasonable for the SRE
team to say, I understand that.
I disagree with your
reasons, and we actually
don't want to support you if you
go and build your own database
technology, because we think
that's not good for production.
SREs are the custodian
of production.
They're the custodian of
the customer experience
for Google.com and for GCP.
So we try to avoid this.
I mean, this may be one or two
times over the history of SRE,
but it has happened.
And it's not the
end of the world.
There are teams
without SRE teams.
They'll survive.
SREs support their
teams in a lot of ways.
It's not just
about taking pages,
although, I can assure
you that's usually
what I'm asked very first
when I'm interviewing someone.
So you guys get paged?
SRE support is on a spectrum.
So it can go, on one end, to
simply chatting with a dev,
consulting with them
about a service,
doing a little
whiteboard session,
to full-on producing
a design doc together.
Or in the very
extreme, yes, actually
fully owning a service,
all of the capacity,
all of the provisioning,
all of the pages.
We don't really think
of pages as the sort
of headliner of what SRE does.
Pages are kind of a way
of keeping you honest.
So the people responsible
for production
should take the
pages because that
keeps their skin in the game.
And it helps keep the
SRE's skill, expertise,
and perspectives up to date.
All right.
Let's talk a little bit
about what makes things go.
Like to talk about the
culture and processes,
but it's not the
scary P processes.
They're good processes.
So in addition to training
and on-call shadowing,
which you guys probably
do at your companies,
we like to run a
role-playing game,
if you will, where one
person is the dungeon master,
and they have a victim,
perhaps a class SRE, level five
lawful neutral alignment,
would be my guess,
onboard the whole team.
And they take turns trying to
guess what's actually going on.
We run very complex
systems at Google,
with a lot of
different dependencies.
So it's rare that someone
other than the dungeon
master or the person running the
training session actually fully
knows what the answer is.
It's good for our
new on-callers.
It let's them actually
test things out
in a controlled environment.
Some teams actually even have
entire scenarios they can run,
where they actually
break something in Prod
and have the newbies fix it.
But it's also good
for the veterans.
When you have very
involved systems,
it's good to refresh
your knowledge,
it's good figure,
oh, that's right.
That's how that thing works.
All right.
Brief break in the
talk for a quiz.
So you're on call for Gmail.
You get a ticket
that says, users
can see other users' emails.
What you do?
Do you call your team lead?
Call your VP?
Call for a pizza?
Or do you shut it down?
I actually ran the test on
this with some non-Googlers.
Most people answer
A. The answer is
D. Our on-callers are fully
empowered to do whatever
it takes to protect the
users, to protect information,
to protect Google.
And if that means
shutting down Gmail,
if that means shutting
down all of Google.com,
you, that college hire who's
six months at a school, who just
got paged for your
first time, are
going to be
supported by your VP,
by your SVP for shutting it
down and protecting Google.
And we actually don't need
to worry about making sure
that we troubleshoot.
Our goal is to restore
service immediately.
We have records of the
binary state, we have logs.
We'll troubleshoot
when we're awake,
when the devs are in the office,
when everyone's actually there.
We just want to get it
back up and in service now.
All right.
Next quiz.
Everyone still awake?
When good software goes bad.
So you have a new dev.
Maybe this is another college
hire, but on the dev side.
The new dev pushed code, broke
Google.com, the entire search
engine, for three hours.
Who's at fault, the dev,
quality of the code reviews,
lack of tasks, lack of
proper canary process,
lack of rapid rollback tools?
Everything except the new dev.
The new dev shows up
and writes crap code
that take down your site,
it is not fault of the dev.
It's all the gates between
that dev and working
Prod that should
have stopped him,
and that's where you
should be looking.
Yes, people can screw up.
But most the time,
human error should never
have been allowed to actually
propagate beyond the human,
at least not as far as Prod.
That brings us to our, probably,
most critical culture point
of all.
Just blameless postmortems.
Studies show that most
incidents are actually
caused by human error.
You heard Joe say that they
gotten the incident rate down
really far in the data centers?
That's awesome.
Software has not yet, including
software written by SREs.
We still have as the
highest cause, human error
of one form or another.
And it turns out,
incidents are best
solved when you know
what actually happened.
You know the best way to
not know what happened?
Open every incident with
trying to find someone
to point a finger at.
Because people are really good.
They become really
good hiding and making
sure there's no
trail, and making sure
you don't actually
know what happened.
And you just made your
job 10 times harder,
100 times harder,
1,000 times harder.
So avoiding a blame
culture is critical.
At Google, the general practice
is, whoever screwed up writes
the postmortem.
This avoids naming and shaming.
This gives them the
power to make it right.
Multiple people contributed,
which is very common.
Everyone goes in, as
honest as possible,
put in how you screwed up.
We've actually given bonuses
out at All Hands Meetings
for taking down the
site, because it
was someone who owned up
immediately that they did it.
IRC, oh boy.
Hang on, guys.
Rolled it back, and
they got a bonus
for speaking up and taking
care of it so quickly.
And in the event
of major outages,
it's actually not unheard
of for a VP or an SVP
to kind of ping someone
to say, it's OK.
It's OK.
No one's blaming you've.
We've got your back.
It'll be all right.
Blameless doesn't mean
there's not names or details.
Obviously, we need
to look into that.
But it means we're not picking
the people as the reason
things went wrong.
There shouldn't be any such
thing as an outage that
deserves a firing.
We have a detailed
postmortem template
that separates out actions
and to prevent, detect,
and mitigate, because we
want defense in-depth.
We don't want to
just go, yeah, well,
we did all those things
that we needed to do,
and now, it'll
never happen again,
because, ah, odd are good
it'll happen in some way.
Maybe you missed something,
or it comes in another angle,
or whatever.
We want to, yes,
prevent outages.
We also want to detect
them faster and want
to mitigate the impact.
So if something like
this happens again,
it at least won't spread
as far, or last as long,
or affect as many customers.
All righty.
In the short time
remaining, I'd like
to talk a very little bit about
how we actually do our job.
We really lean heavily
on visualizations.
But first, I want to talk
about the kinds of pages
we like to see as a team.
Pages you know how
to solve are boring,
make you ask if there
isn't a better way.
Maybe you should invent a robot.
We invent lots of robots.
We don't like being bored.
We don't want to
sit there, dreaming
of a better world in which we
aren't paged by boring things.
If you can write documentation
to fix it, just fix it.
If you can write down
the steps that clearly,
you could probably
write the automation.
If you can't, go
write something that
lets you write the automation.
Don't be doing things that
robots can do for you.
Pages?
If you're getting
recurring pages,
stop them from happening.
So the result of this
is that each page we get
is, ideally, really new.
So we don't have boredom.
We definitely
don't have boredom.
This means even our experienced
engineers are probably
seeing something new every
single time their pager goes
off.
This is a fundamental
change in philosophy.
If nothing is routine and
few incidents are repeated,
this means you can't
lean as heavily
on your previous experience
when debugging the system.
It means you need much
stronger debugging tools.
This is not a debugging tool.
This is an obfuscated view of
[INAUDIBLE] messages on my Mac,
but you get the point.
Standard debugging, like looking
for patterns in log files,
it doesn't scale if you
don't know what to look for.
And with a platform the size of
GCP, how many machines' logs.
am I going to look
until I hopefully
find the one that was failing?
So we rely very heavily
on various visual tools
to help us troubleshoot
unfamiliar problems
and restore service as
quickly as possible.
Graphing tools?
Oh, sorry.
In the next few slides,
I will have some
Open Source tools mentioned.
I'm not advocating these
tools in particular.
We don't use these tools.
These are examples
of what we do.
So you can use these
as a springboard.
They may be useful.
You may use them to
find other tools.
Graphing is a very traditional
form of visualization.
It's great when you're
looking at a single thing.
It's even better when
you're looking in aggregate.
Processes that we care about at
Google, there's never just one.
There's billions, and
billions, and billions of them.
So each of these lines,
while they look simple,
are actually pulling from
many different sources
and getting aggregated.
We instrument the heck
out of our binaries,
because, again, with
a novel situation,
you don't always know
what you're looking for.
Ideally, you have
a framework that
makes it easy for your
developers to actually export
data into your system.
Developers get bored just
like ops people get bored,
and they have just
as much fun-- none--
writing repetitive
monitoring code.
So come up with a framework,
find a framework, whatever
you need, so that that is
actually simple for your devs
to do.
I mentioned this before.
Possibly most critical
is that there's actually
a huge amount of storage that
we have behind this solely
to store this data,
because we do not
want to be troubleshooting
in the middle of an outage.
An outage is all about
restoring service.
Troubleshooting is what
happens when you're awake.
Our devs are often engaged
in troubleshooting.
They have the deeper knowledge.
They know where
stuff's going on.
So you need to have
this data historically
so you can look at it and not
go, well, we fixed the outage,
but we lost all
the data that was
going to tell us what was
going on in the first place.
This helps keep our unusual
outages as short as possible
and lets us dig into
what goes on later.
Event graphing is really, really
useful for correlating events.
Take advantage of your human
ability to pattern match.
It's actually kind of hard
to write robots to do this,
although, deep minds
solve [INAUDIBLE].
So maybe it will take
this away from us, too.
So this is laying things out
by data center and by time.
And then-- and I
apologize if that's
hard to see back there-- the
color is actually the event
type.
This can help you
find patterns that
aren't single incidents like,
say, a software roll-out that's
causing cascading failures
throughout the whole stack,
or a cluster of errors
that's repeating together,
or if you see a
latency spike, and then
an error spike immediately
after it, and that's repeated.
These will all help you get
to the root cause of what's
actually going on.
Visual process tracing.
I apologize.
I could not actually find a lot
of truly open source options
for this, although there's
a whole bunch of ones
you can pay for.
When you're looking
at performance issues,
you sometimes do need to get
down to the process level.
We have a pretty
elaborate framework
that pulls sample
queries into storage
and actually provides
a full trace of them.
The advantage to
having a tool that
allows you to do it visually
is, you can actually
collapse, and expand, and
compare things a lot better
than if you're looking
at a series of timestamps
and trying to go, OK, how
many milliseconds is there?
Maybe you're better at math
in your head than I am,
I don't know.
I'm not good at it.
Network flows and capacity.
So I work in storage.
It turns out that
a lot of storage
is slow problems--
not all, but many--
are root caused in the network.
And you can be sitting there,
staring at your storage system,
staring at your processes,
and going, what the heck?
And the problem was way,
way, way far away from you
and the networking team.
So being able to
quickly see what's
the state, what links are
overloaded, how many packet
errors are you seeing, is
the link entirely down,
really useful, even if
you are not personally
responsible for the network.
When all else fails-- yeah,
it's all about logfiles
again, unfortunately.
But what you don't
want to be doing
is grepping through these logs.
Having a system that allows you
to have SQL-like queries, where
you can actually dig into them
more sanely than trying to come
up with the correct regular
expression that will filter out
exactly what you want,
extremely useful.
You want your logs to be easy
to consume, easy to understand.
And there's a Open
Source option there.
You can also have Kibana as
a potential visualization.
All right.
Before I end, there
are two more things
I want to bring
to your attention.
One is, if this interests
you, we have a book.
It's not out yet.
It comes out in April, and it's
actually getting officially
announced at SRE Con
next week, but they
told me was allowed
to mention it here.
This is a sample of
some of the topics.
This is not at all
an exhaustive list.
It was written by actual SREs
who are doing actual SRE work.
We had 70 different
contributors,
500 years of Google
expertise into it,
and it's a crazy thick book.
I'm really excited by it.
So if this was
interesting, all of this
is gone into way more detail,
along with some other stuff
in the book.
I highly recommend it.
Also, I don't know
how many of you
were able to be in for
the announcement for this,
but we actually have
gotten one of our tools
to be usable in GCP.
So Stackdriver Error
Reporting, excellent tool, we
would like to do more of this.
We have an extensive
ecosystem internally
that we would like to make
available to our Cloud
customers.
In fact, we would like it to
be available to you, period.
That can be challenging.
But it's a little bit
easier if we can at least
make it available on Cloud.
Errors are grouped
and deduplicated
by analyzing their stack traces.
Talked a little bit
about that before.
And the system knows about
the common frameworks
that you use in your language,
and groups errors accordingly.
So please check it out.
It's very cool.
It's in beta as on,
I believe, today.
All righty.
We are not doing questions.
There we go.
Thank you for your time today.
I made this short so
you all can slip out.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.